hello in this video I'll talk about
protein delivery to lysosome so the
proteins are folded in the ER sorted in
the Golgi bodies and then they are
distributed to several locations inside
the cell maybe some are secreted out or
some are secreted to specific some are
deliver to specific organelles as an
example of the second we'll look at or
we would track a path of a protein which
is going to be delivered to the lysosome
and we know lysosome are organelles
which has many hydrolytic enzymes so
will classically look at the part of
hydrolase enzyme how it is selectively
delivered to the lysosome now Golgi is
just like a warehouse of a cell so Golgi
is kind of a sorting hub where several
protein products are sorted to be
delivered to a specific location and
just like in a warehouse where are many
delivery trucks are there which are
delivering the protein delivering the
product to specific locations of the
city in ecology as well
there are sorting hubs that ensures a
specific protein product either it's
secreted or may be deliver to lysosome
or may be deliver to mitochondria now
the question is how exactly the address
of where the product is going to be
delivered is determined inside the Golgi
definitely there should be on the
product there should be a address tag
right and we would look at what is the
address tag on the protein so the
address tag in the protein is basically
a oligosaccharide tag or RN linked
glycosylation tag which starts in ER and
the glycosylation or process of tagging
is also continuing in the
the apparatus as well now in the Golgi
apparatus this tag is formed in a
sequential manner where several residues
are added and several residues are
chopped off like Manos is chopped off
Gallic 2z is added in acetyl glucosamine
is added etc and at the trans-golgi this
oligosaccharide in linked glycosylation
tag is ready and it is it's displayed on
the surface of the protein that needs to
be delivered one kind of special tag
which allow the protein to be delivered
to the ribose to the lysosome is mannose
6-phosphate tap a tag and phospho
transferase enzyme put a phosphate group
on the mannose residues and this mannose
6-phosphate is that tag or the signal by
which the sorting mechanism knows that
if these particular products are going
to be delivered to the lysosome and not
any other location inside the cell now
there are specific receptors which sort
out this protein from other known as
mannose 6-phosphate receptor present in
the membrane of the trans-golgi network
and the mannose-6-phosphate receptor and
the mannose-6-phosphate
tag interaction happens at a pH around 6
to 6.5 this is important because we will
look at later how this interaction
change and this protein is released into
the lysosome once mannose 6-phosphate
receptor and - 6-phosphate AG interacts
with each other several Triskelion
molecules attaches to it and a
clattering coat is assembled on to them
and clathrin-mediated coat formation and
thereby delivery of those clattering
coated vesicles happen to the lysosome
in the lysosome they fuse with the
lysosomal membrane delivering its
content that means the hydrolase or
lysosomal enzymes into the lysosome now
inside the lysosome
the ph is acidic around 4 or 3 because
there are specific proton pumps onto the
lysosomal membrane which continuously
pumps proton inside as a result the
inside of the lysosome is pretty acidic
as a result the interaction between the
tag the m6 mannose-6-phosphate tag and
the mannose-6-phosphate receptor is
disintegrated and the hydrolase enzyme
is released inside the lysosome this
particular process also ensures that the
protein does not interact with mannose
6-phosphate receptor again because these
mannose-6-phosphate receptors are
actually transferred back onto the
trans-golgi network in a retrograde
fashion if these interaction happens
then the protein would be transferred
back from from which it came from two
things ensure that this back propagation
does not happen one is acidic pH inside
the golgi and second there are specific
enzymes which chops off this mannose
residue this phosphate residue as a
result it cannot interact with them a no
six phosphate receptor and the protein
cannot be delivered back to the
trans-golgi network but the receptors
does and this kind of process sorting
out and putting it into specific
location is very important because if
the transport is improper or the tagging
process is improper then lysosomal
storage disorder could occur where
specific unwanted protein products are
getting accumulated in the ripe lysosome
but cannot be degraded because the
hydrolyzed enzymes are not properly
reaching the lysosome and that's why i
lysosome cannot function optimally so
that is why proper sorting out of the
proteins in the trans-golgi network and
delivering it into its distant location
is very important for the cell I hope
you enjoy this video and hope this video
was informative enough if you like my
video give it a quick thumbs up and
don't for
to like share and subscribe thank you